l'appareil à développement instantané
c'est ça ça fait la photo tout de suite
on va essayer de voilà aujourd'hui c'est
mentir là dessus tu vois combien de
temps ça demande un on retire la et 15
secondes plus tard on à la photo 1966 le
présentateur pierre bellemare et
l'acteur jean poiret s'intéresse au
phénomène polaroïd un objet devenu
aujourd'hui collector et qui pourtant a
bien failli disparaître
l'appareil photo est commercialisé dès
1948 par son inventeur l'américain edwin
land le succès du pôle là est immédiat
les chiffres d'affaires de l'entreprise
atteint les 23 millions de dollars en
seulement deux années d'existence dans
les années 70 l'appareil était toujours
ultra tendance
les appareils photo à développement
instantané sont très appréciés il est
bien agréable de pouvoir obtenir
aussitôt la photo que l'on vient de
prendre si elle est ratée on peut s'en
rendre compte immédiatement et la
recommencer facilité d'utilisation
rapidité de développement à ses débuts
le polaroïd est d'abord destiné au grand
public
ce n'est qu'à la fin des années 70 et
les professionnels santé reste procédé
ces photos d'un grand format ont une
très bonne définition et les couleurs
sont fidèles
les médecins les chercheurs les
photographes industriels et les
publicitaires ont adopté ce procédé
en 1994 la marque atteint son apogée
avec 2,3 milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires puis arrive le numérique à la
fin des années 90 l'instantané paula
n'est plus à la mode et l'entreprise ben
à innover résultat en 2001 c'est la
faillite pour polaroid l'heure du déclin
sony dépôt de bilan dette estimée à plus
de 7 milliards de francs
l'image du géant de la photo instantanée
sera bientôt à ranger dans les albums
souvenirs de l'industrie photographique
les fermetures d'usinés s'enchaînent on
salariés décident alors de racheter les
machines pour sauver polaroïd sous le
nom 10ème possible project il relance la
production des films pour les appareils
instantanés et en quelques innovations
numériques et ça marche
le charme du pôle a séduit les nouvelles
générations le retour de polaroïd je
crois que c'est saturation delà de
l'image parfait numérique qui qui est
très moderne qui donne une image exacte
et les gens ils ont rejoint votre
fantasy l'autre défi pour polaroid est à
présent de résister face à son principal
concurrent fujifilm la marque japonaise
détient tout de même aujourd'hui 90% du
marché de la photographie instantanée
[Musique]